straight night these garden fans 2
000 strong and loud on their feet giving
the team
a standing ovation as the knicks are
going to
continue their longest winning streak in
seven years
and the garden again becoming the next
xanadu and there it is
eight wins in a row this season of hope
this season of promise continues
as top feminists find a way to win again
last time they had an eight-game winning
streak the man in attendance tonight
mike woodson was the head coach
and the rookie one of several licks
with huge contributions and smiles all
around for the nixon here in the stands
and now the dick's sole possession
of fourth place in the eastern
conference with just 12 games to play
extraordinary clyde it is mike i like
the way the team is playing i like the
defensive intensity the sharon and carry
on the offense randall continues to
astound
most improved player trying to lock up
that award
though a signed jersey goes to mike
woodson again we saw before the game
just how beloved and respected mike
woodson is
so many of the nick players went over to
embrace him
this is the fifth time this season clyde
the knicks have won both games
of a back-to-back scenario and that was
unheard of
in the last four or five years for the
knicks obviously this one both games at
home
hawks also played last night
[Applause]
there's greg schwartz the next media
relations department
and julius randle
so thrilled
that gets his wife kendra's approval
and just another brilliant performance
from julius randle
we said it last night it might and i'm
just proud of my guys proud of everybody
we fought to the end
there's a lot of times we could have let
go of the road we didn't and we just
kept going like we've been doing all
year you mentioned your guys
19 made threes from this team tonight it
has just been extraordinary how well you
guys have been
hitting that three ball what has been
working for this team
uh we're just a bunch of guys who bring
a hard hat every day
uh not just to the game uh guys work
really hard
um practicing doing what they need to do
to get prepared so
uh you know it just translates to the
game julius congrats
new york we're here
he made his first all-star team he's the
leading candidate for the most improved
player
might even make an all-nba team and more
importantly
trying to lead the new york knicks back
to the nba postseason
eight straight wins for the knicks 40
more points for randall
next win here at the guard we'll be back